THERE WILL BE MASSIVE LAYOFFS AT
THE STATE AND LOCAL LEVEL UNLESS
WE GET SOME MONEY TO THEM
QUICKLY.
>> Neil: THAT WAS
CHUCK SCHUMER RESPOND TO
COMMENTS MADE BY
MITCH McCONNELL.
STATES COULD ALWAYS APPLY FOR
BANKRUPTCY.
THE SENATOR JOINS US RIGHT NOW
ON THE PHONE.
MITCH McCONNELL, VERY GOOD TO
HAVE YOU.
THIS IS GOING TO THOSE DIRECTLY
IMPACTED BY THE CORONAVIRUS.
>> WEIRD CERTAINLY OPEN TO
CONSIDERING ADDITIONAL
ASSISTANCE TO STATE AND LOCAL
GOVERNMENTS ON TOP OF WHAT WE’VE
ALREADY DONE IN THE CARES ACT.
IT IS IMPORTANT TO UNDERSTAND
THAT MANY STATES HAVE STEMMED TO
LONG CHALLENGES.
PENSION FUND, MANY OF THEM FROM
OVERSPENDING.
WHAT WE’RE SAYING HERE IS, WE
ARE NOT INTERESTED IN RESCUING
BADLY RUN STATES FROM THE
MISTAKES THEY’VE MADE COMPLETELY
UNRELATED TO THE CORONAVIRUS.
SO LET ME MAKE IT PERFECTLY
CLEAR.
WE ARE OPEN TO CONSIDERING
ANOTHER BILL.
MY REDLINE GOING FORWARD ON THIS
BILL IS TO PROVIDE PROTECTION,
LITIGATION PROTECTION FOR THOSE
WHO HAVE BEEN ON THE FRONTLINE.
HOSPITALS, DOCTORS, NURSES.
IMAGINE YOU ARE A BUSINESSMAN
THINKING ABOUT REOPENING.
AND YOU’VE HEARD THAT THE TRIAL
LAWYERS ALL OVER THE COUNTRY ARE
SHARPENING THEIR PENCILS GETTING
READY TO SUE YOU, CLAIMING THAT
YOU DIDN’T ENGAGE IN PROPER
DISTANCING OR OTHER ISSUES
RELATED TO HEALTH AND SAFETY.
LOOK, WE CAN’T PASS ANOTHER BILL
UNLESS WE HAVE LIABILITY
PROTECTIONS.
THAT’S THE ONLY WAY WE’RE GOING
TO BE ABLE TO GET PAST THIS.
THAT’S TO BEGIN TO OPEN UP THE
ECONOMY AGAIN.
WE HAVE TO HAVE BUSINESS IS
BRAVE ENOUGH TO OPEN UP AGAIN
AND EMPLOYEES BRAVE ENOUGH TO GO
BACK TO WORK.
AND I’M GLAD TO SEE THAT SOME OF
THE STATES ARE BEGINNING TO MOVE
IN THE DIRECTION OF REOPENING.
>> Neil: ALL RIGHT, BUT YOU
ARE ALREADY, YOUR IDEA MAYBE IT
WAS SOMETHING YOU THROUGHOUT
THERE, THE REFORM COULD BE PART
OF MORE AID TO THE STATES.
NANCY PELOSI RESPONDED THE
DEMOCRATS ARE NOT INTERESTED IN
COVID-19 REFORM.
THE HOUSE HAS NO INTEREST IN
DIMINISHING PROTECTIONS FOR
EMPLOYEES AND CUSTOMERS.
WHAT DO YOU SAY TO THAT?
>> LET ME MAKE IT PERFECTLY
CLEAR, THE SENATOR IS NOT
INTERESTING IN PASSING A BILL
THAT DOES NOT HAVE LIABILITY
PROTECTION.
THAT IS AN INTEGRAL PART OF OUR
ECONOMY GETTING BACK TO NORMAL.
SO WE ARE GOING BACK TO WORK.
THIS AND IS COMING BACK MONDAY.
WE ARE PERFECTLY WILLING TO
DISCUSS THE WAY FORWARD.
THE WAY THAT YOU MAKE A LAW IS
PASSED THE HOUSE AND THE SENATE.
WHAT I’M SAYING IS, WE HAVE A
REDLINE ON LIABILITY.
IT WON’T PASS THE SENATE WITHOUT
IT.
>> Neil: SO WHAT WOULD HAPPEN,
SENATOR, ABOUT BUSINESS FEELING
EMBOLDENED BY LIABILITY
PROTECTION THAT IT DOESN’T DO
SOME BASIC THINGS LIKE MASKS AND
OTHER PROTECTION FOR WORKERS
BECAUSE IT MIGHT FEEL THAT IT IS
LEGALLY BULLETPROOF AND DOESN’T
HAVE TO?
>> THAT’S A GOOD QUESTION.
AFTER CAREFULLY CRAFT THE
LIABILITY PROTECTION TO DEAL
WITH THE MONEY THAT WOULD BE
SUPPLIED TO STATE AND LOCAL
GOVERNMENT, CONDITIONED UPON
THEM AND ACTING AT THE STATE
LEVEL, THAT KIND OF LEGISLATION
THAT WOULD PROVIDE LIABILITY
PROTECTION FOR THOSE WHO ARE
SEEKING TO GO FORWARD AND TO GET
THE ECONOMY BACK UP TO WORK.
LOOK, NEIL, I’VE BEEN TALKING TO
BUSINESS PEOPLE ALL OVER THE
COUNTRY.
THERE IS A GOOD DEAL OF FEAR
ABOUT GETTING BACK TO NORMAL.
KNOWING FULL WELL THE LOSSES
THAT ARE WAITING UNLESS WE
ADDRESS THIS ISSUE.
THIS IS AN INTEGRAL PART OF
GETTING THE ECONOMY BACK UP AND
RUNNING AND GETTING THE COUNTRY
BACK UP AND RUNNING.
AND THAT WILL BE A CONDITION FOR
PROVIDING ADDITIONAL ASSISTANCE
TO STATE AND LOCAL GOVERNMENT.
>> Neil: LET ME ASK YOU,
SENATOR.
HE MADE SOME NEWS IN THIS
REPORT.
I’M SURE YOU’VE HEARD ABOUT
WHERE YOU SAID WE NEED TO GET
THE WHITE HOUSE DEMOCRATS IN A
BOX.
BOTH NEED TO GET THE MESSAGE.
YOU ARE REFERRING TO
INFRASTRUCTURE.
AT THE PRESIDENT INTIMATED TODAY
IN A SMALL BUSINESS CONFERENCE
THAT HE WAS STILL OPEN TO THAT.
THE NOTION THAT MAY BE THAT YOU
ARE IN DISAGREEMENT.
MAYBE I COULD GET SOME CLARITY
FROM YOU.
ARE YOU OPEN AND WOULD YOU AGREE
TO INFRASTRUCTURE SPENDING AS
PART OF A FUTURE STIMULUS RELIEF
PLAN?
>> WE HAVE AN EQUAL INTEREST IN
DOING AN INFRASTRUCTURE BILL.
WE DON’T HAVE AN EQUAL INTEREST
IN BORROWING MONEY FOR FUTURE
GENERATIONS TO PAY FOR IT.
IT IS UNRELATED TO THE
CORONAVIRUS PANDEMIC WHICH IS
THE REASON WHY WE HAVE RUN UP
THE NATIONAL DEBT TO
$.8 TRILLION.
I AGREE WITH THE PRESIDENT,
INFRASTRUCTURE IS IMPORTANT.
I JUST DON’T BELIEVE THAT WE
SHOULD BE BORROWING ADDING TO
THE NATIONAL DEBT.
WE’VE ADDED $2.8 TRILLION TO THE
NATIONAL DEBT IN THE LAST MONTH.
I JUST DON’T THINK THAT IS THE
PATH TO GETTING AN
INFRASTRUCTURE BILL.
I DO AGREE THAT WITH HIM THAT WE
NEED TO DO THAT.
WE ARE GOING TO PASS A MORE
MODEST INFRASTRUCTURE BILL IN
THE SENATE IN THE NEAR FUTURE
SINCE WE ARE COMING BACK TO WORK
NEXT MONDAY.
>> Neil: JUST TO BE CLEAR, AS
FAR AS THE NEXT ROUND OF
STIMULUS, YOU DO NOT WANTED TO
BE INFRASTRUCTURE.
AM I GETTING THAT RIGHT?
>> YEAH, INFRASTRUCTURE IS
UNRELATED TO THE CORONAVIRUS
PANDEMIC THAT WE ARE ALL
EXPERIENCING AND TRYING TO
FIGURE OUT HOW TO GO FORWARD.
WE’VE BORROWED AN INCREDIBLE
AMOUNT OF MONEY HERE OVER THE
LAST MONTH.
AND WE NEED TO MAKE SURE THAT
WHATEVER ADDITIONAL EXPLANATION
WE DO IS DIRECTLY RELATED TO
THIS PANDEMIC AND TO TRY TO GET
IT IN THEIR REARVIEW MIRROR AND
GET THE COUNTRY BACK UP AND
RUNNING AGAIN.
>> Neil: SENATOR, WHILE I HAVE
YOU HERE, YOU MADE AN
INTERESTING COMMENT WHEN YOU ARE
TALKING TO FOX NEWS RADIO IN
WHICH YOU ARE DESCRIBING MAY BE
SOME OF THE PROBLEMS AROUND THE
PRESIDENT HEALTH CARE TASK FORCE
BRIEFINGS IN WHICH HE SAID
AMERICAN PEOPLE ARE MOST
INTERESTED IN THE ADVICE FROM
THE HELP PROFESSIONALS OF HOW TO
CONDUCT THEIR LIVES SAFELY.
ARE YOU SAYING THAT THE
PRESIDENT SHOULDN’T TALK AS MUCH
MUCH?
>> NOW, I WASN’T SAYING THAT.
BUT I THINK THE AMERICAN PEOPLE
ARE INTERESTED IN WHAT OUR
HEALTH EXPERTS HAVE TO SAY ABOUT
THIS PANDEMIC.
WE’VE NEVER HAD THIS PARTICULAR
DISEASE BEFORE.
THEY ARE ANXIOUS TO GET
INFORMATION ABOUT HOW TO CONDUCT
THEIR LIVES CONSISTENTLY WITH
THE RECOMMENDATION.
SO WE CAN SAFELY GO ABOUT OUR
BUSINESS.
ONE OF THE REASONS WE PUT
$25 BILLION IN THE ADDITIONAL
BILL OVER AND ABOVE THAT CARES
BILL THAT WE PASSED LAST WEEK
FOR TESTING IS, WE ARE NOT THERE
YET ON TESTING.
NOT ONLY WHAT KIND OF TEST BUT
HOW MANY OF THEM ACTUALLY WILL
TELL YOU SOMETHING OTHER THAN
YOU DON’T HAVE IT AT THE MOMENT.
AND WE DON’T YET HAVE TREATMENT.
AND WE DON’T YET HAVE A VACCINE.
WE’VE ALLOCATED $25 BILLION AT
THAT WHOLE AREA OF TESTING AND
TREATMENT AND VACCINE IN THE
BILL THAT WE JUST PASSED LAST
WEEK.
THAT’S ALL PART OF REASSURING
EVERYONE THAT THEY CAN SAFELY GO
BACK TO WORK.
>> Neil: I GUESS WHAT I’M
ASKING IS WHETHER YOU WANTED TO
RESTRUCTURE THEIR BRIEFINGS AS
THEY ARE NOW.
TO THE EXTENT OF THE WHITE HOUSE
DECIDES TO RE-CRAFT THESE
BRIEFINGS TO REFLECT THAT GOAL,
THE MEDICAL INFORMATION FROM THE
EXPERTS, THAT’S PROBABLY GOOD
IDEA.
WHAT SPECIFICALLY
>> YEAH, I DON’T HAVE ANY ADVICE
TO GIVE THE WHITE HOUSE ABOUT
HOW TO HANDLE THE BRIEFING.
I DON’T HAVE ANY ADVICE TO GIVE
THEM AT ALL.
>> Neil: SO YOU ARE NOT
MEANING TO IMPLY THAT THESE, ANY
COMMENTS APART FROM THE MEDICAL
EXPERTS WERE NOT NECESSARY?
>> NO, I WASN’T.
I DID THINK THAT THE MEDICAL
EXPERTS ARE THE ONES THAT THE
PUBLIC IS MOST INTERESTED IN FOR
OBVIOUS REASONS, BECAUSE THEY
ARE INTERESTED IN HOW THEY CAN
GO ABOUT THEIR BUSINESS SAFELY.
>> Neil: FINALLY, SENATOR, THE
PRESIDENT TALKED ABOUT A
V-SHAPED RECOVERY, GOING TO BE
TOUGH GIVEN THE STAGGERING
NATURE OF OPENING UP, ARE YOU
WORRIED THAT THAT IS GOING TO BE
TOUGH.
THERE WILL BE AN ECONOMIC PICKUP
AS PEOPLE GET BACK, BUT IF IT
MIGHT TAKE A WHILE TO GET GOING.
ARE YOU IN THE CAMP THAT IT WILL
BE A SHARP INCREASE OR A SLOW
ONE?
>> HONESTLY, NEIL, I DON’T KNOW.
WE ARE IN A PLACE THAT WE HAVE
NEVER BEEN BEFORE WHERE WE ARE
ALL HOPING FOR A RAPID RECOVERY.
I THINK THAT WE GETTING MORE
RAPID RECOVERY IF WE HAVE
LIABILITY REFORM.
IF WE HAVE TESTING THAT
REASSURES PEOPLE, BECAUSE THE
ECONOMY WILL NOT TRULY BE OPEN
UNLESS EVERYONE WILL PARTICIPATE
IN THE ECONOMY AGAIN.
I’M NOT AN EXPERT ON THESE
THINGS.
THIS IS AN EXPERIENCE WE HAVE
NOT HAD BEFORE.
IT IS HARD TO FIGURE OUT WHAT
WILL HAPPEN.
WE DO KNOW THAT WE NEED TO MOVE
AHEAD.
AND I AM PLEASED THAT THE NUMBER
OF STATES ARE BEGINNING TO MOVE
IN THE DIRECTION OF OPENING UP
THE ECONOMY CONSISTENT WITH THE
PHASE 1 RECOMMENDATIONS OF THE
WHITE HOUSE.
THE CORONAVIRUS TASK FORCE.